and now you're done with lesson two but
who you've made a huge step in being
able to transfer data from a server and
bring it all the way down to your device
think about all the possibilities now of
valuable information you could bring
down to users to be available at their
fingertips and that's pretty powerful
speaking about making an impact have you
thought about what you're going to do
for your final project yet you can
choose any topic that you want share
your ideas in the class discussion forum
and you can share with your friends on
social media to over tomato now while I
take a quick nap on the Sun pillow I'll
see you in lesson three